a session dedicated voice ah Janice and
I'll personally about presenting another
penis thanks Elena
so um if you look on the schedule there
these two I saw Jeannie talks in the
morning in principle I'm supposed to
talk about the assumptions and Chloe
Martindale is supposed to talk about the
attacks you can't really talk about the
assumptions without also talking about
the attacks and so we've we've decided
to coordinate together and present the
material in in some way that we see best
so I may not strictly stick just to the
assumptions but I think that I Sajha
knees are just despite appearances
rather the perfect talk for this kind of
a workshop because they do involve
quantum algorithms and surprisingly they
do involve lightest algorithms as well
so you get a little bit of both even
though even though it's not it's not
strictly speaking any sort of lattice
space crypto system you do need to pull
together all of this material and all
these ideas from from different areas of
mathematics and computer science and you
know quantum and all of these things in
order to you know in order to make
progress in this subject and so that
that's one of the reasons why I like it
so much so no further ado let's uh try
to get going here I start with a small
presentation about what elliptic curves
are I hope most people know this already
my main reason here is not to teach you
about elliptic curves if you don't
already know that that would be very
difficult but you know just to fix the
notation and to emphasize some of the
ideas that I'm going to need later so
for our purposes I'm elliptic curve is
going to be a curve defined by a short
virus sauce equation something that
looks like this y squared equals x cubed
plus ax plus B all elliptic curves over
the reals look like this kind of blue
curve or something very similar to it I
want to highlight that there's a group
law the group law is usually defined
geometrically you take two points you
draw the secant through them it
intersects the curve in the third point
you flip the curve around the x axis
that gives you the sum of the two points
all right this this geometry is
sometimes used
when when you know trying to define a
sahjhan he says you need to know sort of
how how the how the earth and it comes
from that geometry there is a point at
infinity but it is not one of the blue
points the point at infinity is is sort
of not drawable in the sort of regular
XY plane but it is the identity element
for the curve so it is it's rather
important from the point of view of
understanding the curve as a group to
know that the you know where the where
the identity element is it's this point
at infinity so what are I saw Jenise i
sahjhan these are algebraic maps between
elliptic curves that preserve the group
structure okay so we we asked for a
function from one elliptic curve to
another elliptic curve we asked for this
function to be algebraic in other words
each coordinate is a rational function
these are two variable rational
functions because you have to Bert you
have x and y you have two variables on
elliptic curve so you're gonna have two
variable rational functions meaning just
quotients of polynomials but in two
variables and you have two of them you
have two coordinates right because you
have the x coordinate and the y
coordinate as output so you need two
rational functions and we ask that it be
a group homomorphism okay so this is we
can take this as a as a definition of an
I saw Janee I would I'll give some
examples of these later I'm not going to
go sort of too much into them I saw
Janee based cryptography has a
reasonable history by now the first
public sort of appearance of crypto
systems based misogynist in literature
was 2006 yeah we have some papers from
2006 there is a hash function proposed
by Charles Gordon and louder and there
are public key cryptosystems there's one
bike Cove aeneas also proposed by rostov
stuff and stole being off it's
essentially the same crypto system those
were published in 2006 although if you
look on Co vain uses paper he has a
paragraph of the beings stating the
origins of his scheme were actually in
1997 he came up with this scheme in 1997
but never published it until 2006
so CRS nowadays we call it CRS by the
initials of the three
authors is one sort of flavor of I saw
Janee based cryptography and another
flavor of I saw tuna based public key
cryptography is what we nowadays call si
D H which stands for super singular I
saw Jenny diffie-hellman so this is a
second scheme that was invented by
myself and Luca de feo in 2011 and then
more recently we have a third scheme
Seaside CSI D H invented by kasparek
langa Martindale pani where are you
Lawrence somewhere over here renters who
I don't think is here and so I I like to
use a simple Venn diagram to explain the
relationship between these things it's
you know so there is the sort of schemes
that use complex multiplication there's
the schemes that use super singular
curves and their seaside which is the
middle that uses both and this is not a
value judgment this is just a sort of
statement of facts as to where we're at
each worksheet where each of these sort
of schemes sits okay I'll go through
briefly some examples that I saw to use
how to construct them I think that for
the purposes of you know this talk it's
enough to understand that I saw two
knees are in fact group homomorphism
because they are group homes they have a
kernel here it is that's the standard
definition of a kernel in group theory
and one thing you can prove about I saw
Jenice using geometry using the geometry
of the curve is that whenever you have a
finite subgroup of an elliptic curve you
can essentially you can mod out by that
finite subgroup and you can get a nice
ogyny which represents the quotient map
right so you can always take and it's
not like you know given given a starting
curve e and a kernel K you can construct
a projection map from e to e mod K and
there is an elliptic curve structure on
emod K like you know e modulo any finite
subgroup gives you an elliptic curve and
the projection map can be interpreted as
a nice najin e and modulo some details
you know and by the way there's there's
lots of simplifying details there's lots
of simplification of details going on
in this talk for example you know
elliptic curves don't all look like this
in characteristic two right and so on
but you know I hope that you can forgive
me for these over simplifications so you
know sweeping a lot of details on the
rug for every such choice of curve and
finite subgroup there is essentially a
unique ISO Janee that has that starts
from that curve and annihilates that
kernel all right so you mod K is
essentially unique and the ISO Janee the
projection map is essentially unique i
sahjhan these have a degree which can be
it's defined as the degree of the
outbreak map in the setting of finite
sub groups and kernels that degree can
be taken as just the size of the kernel
okay so however however the cardinality
it's a finite sub group so the
cardinality of that kernel and whatever
it is that's a finite number that's your
degree okay so that's the degree of the
Asajj knee we have a set of formulas
called V lose formalism it thereby fail
you of course that construct this isogen
you for us that give us equations for
this I saw SHINee
so high if I haven't looked at curve and
I finite sub group then I can use they
lose formulas to get an equation for
this I saw right and that doesn't sound
too hard right so you can just do it
here's here is an example of Baileys
form is this is not the full formulas is
just like a special case this is the
special case where the kernel has two
elements okay so you take an elliptic
curve you take a finite subgroup suppose
your finite circle has two elements of
course it has to be a group right so P
plus P has to be the identity alright so
there you go P plus P is a 10d if you go
back and remember your group law right
so P plus P means the secant line
through a PNP which means the tangent
line through P and the third point has
to be on this tangent line has to be the
point of infinity which means the line
has to be a vertical line and your curve
is symmetric around the x-axis so this
vertical line has to sort of cross the
curve at a point where Y is zero I see
that's that's that's where the group law
comes into all this you reason all this
out he's you realize that okay so in
order to have a subgroup of size two you
need of course you need the identity
element and you need a point of order 2
and the point of order 2 has a white
than equal to zero so that's what this
equation tells you is that the
y-coordinate of the curve is zero okay
and under these conditions if you run
this sort of expression through values
formula to get the the corresponding I
saw Janee with this kernel then these
are what you get right so this is this
is what pops out of a lose formula
obviously this is not like super
simplified that you can simplify this
more like that this a this a you could
simplify this a little more but this is
like the raw expression that you get out
of a lose formula okay and it's not too
bad right you see that you know well
there's there's a you know rational
function here there's a rational
function here you can kind of you know
XP is the point coming from the the
kernel right so you see all these things
here everything here is it's perfectly
you know sort of elementary and you know
understandable you can do the same thing
for larger degrees right so let's take
an arbitrary ice let's take a legal nice
lodging of degree three which means a
kernel of size three okay so you have a
group a subgroup of size three of course
the identity has to be there and then
what you have a group of size three you
need like P and minus P basically that's
the only way to get a group of size
three right and P plus P plus P is equal
to zero and so here you do you to do
some other geometric calculation you
realize that a point of order three has
to be like an inflection point on the
curve it has to be a point worthy like
ii d wat what is it d squared Y DX
squared equals zero has to be one of
these inflection points for similar
reasons as to why the point of order two
has to have Y coordinates here right so
then you do the differentiation you find
that here is the algebraic condition for
being an inflection point
so here the y coordinate is not zero so
but it's just the square root of
whatever this cubic is right and you run
this expression you run these numbers to
reveal this formula and here's what you
get right and again it's not super
complicated right it's yeah that there's
a rational function here there's a
rational function here there's more
terms here than in the previous case
right there are more cures here you have
like a couple of terms here like three
terms in the fraction in the zone right
so these things get more and more
complicated as you go on and so the fact
that these get more
complicated is sort of one of the things
that you have to work around when you're
doing any sort of you know non-trivial
computations with a sahjhan ease okay so
when you want to know what company you
want to compute with I saw Chinese of
large degree you cannot do it head-on
and so the sort of most most of
computational research in AI sahjhan YZ
is sort of about devising ways to get
around this problem right where you
can't compute directly I sahaja needs a
very large degree what's gonna happen is
that the the number that the complexity
of the sort of formula blows up roughly
according to D cubed right maybe it's d
squared I don't know it's something like
that it's in any case infeasible when D
is large right well I largely mean
cryptographic size right you know
hundred digit numbers or something like
that
okay so you can't do it directly you
have to use either you know tricks to do
it or you have to design your scheme to
take this into account or only some
something along those lines here's an
example of what I mean
so in s idh which is the scheme that i
published with DeFeo in 2011 on what we
do in s idh is we use I saw to use of
large degree but those large degrees are
are special they're not like random
numbers there are powers of two or
powers of three or powers of some small
prime and when you have a group which is
a kernel group a kernel which is a
cyclic group of size two to the e for
some power of two then you can you can
sort of factor the group not not
directly as a direct product but
factored in terms of like in group
theory terms right as a sort of
extension power right
everything is abelian so there's nothing
there's there's nothing like you know
hard group theoretically going on here
you just factor as a power of sort of
extensions of degree two and then each
of these extensions corresponds to a
nice launch knee and each of these I saw
chimneys has degree 2 and a degree 2 ice
dodging is easy it's like you know two
slides ago there that's an ice dodging
of a treaty right so you can do that and
then you just compose all of these
isogen ease and you have the overall ice
on you have degree 2
the right now if you try to write that
composition out as a single rational
function it would be very hard you would
get complex like you know plugging a
degree to expression into another degree
to expression and doing that over and
over again rapidly sort of gives you
something unmanageable but you could
evaluate it with you know without
writing it down as a single rational
expression and it's fine all right so
then you just you just evaluate the I
saw seen in that way so that is that is
how you get I sahjhan ease of large
degree now these are special degrees
their degree to 2 to the right something
you can't do all of the isawesome this
way but this is all you need for SI th
ok so here is a quick I guess very quick
overview of si DHI describe the scheme
so that then the assumption makes sense
right if I'm gonna talk about the
assumptions that you use in public key
cryptography but I know I'm only going
to talk about si DHC side and CRS in
this talk I'm not going to talk about
the hash function that the title says
public key cryptography so I'm only
doing public key cryptography here all
right
so in I say th the scheme is sort of
easily summarized in this small diagram
it looks like this basically you start
with a curve that's like a public
parameter and then your secret is gonna
be the kernel right so each party Alice
and Bob is it's a key exchange so each
Alice and Bob each choose like a kernel
as their secret and then they publish
sort of the quotient of the original
curve by that kernel as their public key
right and when they want to do key
exchange each one sort of mods out by
both kernels right so Alice knows a and
Alice still it's a mod B so
theoretically L should be able to
compute like emod be mod a or something
like that you might be mod a which would
give you a modulo both of them right and
Bob does the same thing with the B's and
I switched and so that gives you a key
exchange which looks at least out of at
a very zoomed out level looks a lot like
Debbie Ullman all right in the details
it differs by quite a bit of course and
there's this is an oversimplification
again there are certain things that you
have to do in order to actually make
this work for example you know in order
for so let's say you're Bob and you
emod a and you have B right well it's
not enough just to do Ahmad a mod B that
doesn't make sense B is not a subgroup
of Ahmad a you need Ahmad a modular Phi
a of B you need to transport be through
Alice's I saw Tunis but that was
supposed to be secret right so you can't
literally do that so what you have to do
is Alice has to give like extra
information essentially she has to give
the matrix representing her ice Naja
neon Bob's on the sort of space Colonel
space the space of possible kernels
right so you have to give this extra
information and there are there are
papers that do exploits this extra
information to attack not si gates
directly but various versions of us well
there's a paper that attacks it with an
active attack there's the Gail brief GP
GP st paper that attacks it directly so
there are some attacks that you can do
if you exploit that information but for
a lack of time I'm just gonna cover the
very basics right so the basic attack
these sort of the foundational hard
problem the heart the part of the
problem that sort of underlies
everything that must be secured in order
that must be hard in order for si DHT to
be secure is the problem that I have
listed right here give an e and e mod a
find a actually give an E and you're
given the sort of the the quotient curve
e modulo some secret kernel that you
don't know you want to find that super
kernel and here the the the fastest
known algorithm is pretty easy to
explain what you do is so you recall
that to get from e to e mod a is a
sequence of two I saw Chinese alright
and so what you're gonna do in order to
attack this scheme is you're just gonna
walk along all the possible to I saw any
paths until you get from here to there
okay now if you start it from here and
try to get all the way to here at each
stage there are three possible to a
sahjhan ease again
oversimplifying but usually there are
three possible to i swatched knees and
so you know it's gonna it's gonna be
this now yeah let's let's say you get
from here to here now there are three
possible to I saw SHINee's one of them
goes backwards of course to where you
started with than the other
to go forward and so you're you get this
sort of branching sort of search right
where you have to you have to search
east eps and at each step there are two
ways you can go right so naively this is
like you know degree phi is the number
of you know things you have to try but
of course you know both end points so
you don't have to go from e all the way
to the end you can start from each end
point and meet in the middle right so
that makes sure to sort of attack a
little bit faster if you work out the
math as to how long this takes i didn't
put it on the slides but roughly
speaking in a classical attack this
takes square root of the degree you know
steps in order to get in order to meet
in the middle and in the quantum setting
it could argue that it takes cube root
of the degree and the reason for the
cube root is that it's cut it's a it's a
well-known algorithm it's like taani
collision search or claw finding search
what you do is you have this thing
called Grover's algorithm right which
can quadratically speed up any sort of
quantum search you can't you can't
productively use Grover's directly but
what you can do is you can sort of go
one third of the way and then use
Grover's on the remaining two-thirds
right and so that that gives you this
one third exponent now whether or not
the taani approach actually saves you
any time in practice given you know our
current knowledge of models of
computation quantum computation is is a
subject of debate I think the the latest
word on this subject is Jackson shank
skanks paper from from crypto last year
so it's not it's not clear whether or
not you can actually get get this number
there there's some there there are some
issues there but I'm not going to talk
about those you can look at this paper
if you want if you want more information
on that okay so that is si th let's talk
about the other thing so
I'm going to talk about CRS and Seaside
and I'm basically going to talk about
them together because from the
standpoint of anything that I that we
care about here you know they're they're
similar enough that the attacks the same
attacks in principle work on both of
course in the details they you know
they're there are differences and but
the later talks by Khloe and Kris will
we'll focus more on those details all
right so I'm just I'm just gonna go sort
of very very high level conceptual
overview of these these games and what
they are what they do okay all right
so in order to set up let's say CRS
which is easier to talk about you want
to use the fact that this is one known a
well-known fact from theoretical you
know mathematics arithmetic geometry
that there is a group action
corresponding to an elliptic curve if
you have if you have an elliptic curve
which is ordinary I let that is not
super singular right so in the ordinary
case you can take an action where the
ideal class group of the endomorphism
ring of the curve acts on like the set
of all elliptic curves with that
endomorph some ring right and I've
denoted that set by this the script I ll
write so the set of all elliptic curves
with that endomorph some ring can be
acted on by endomorphisms essentially
but but the action is sort of
well-defined modulo principle ideals and
so it ends up being just an action on
the ideal class group which is fortunate
for us because now we have a group right
and here's the definition of the action
it's it's not it's not that hard as long
as you sort of unwind things a little
bit right so what you're gonna do is
you're gonna take your to act you know
by and endomorphism on a night by by an
ideal on a curve what you're gonna do is
you're gonna essentially you're gonna
mod out by the intersection of all the
kernels of all the elements in the ideal
that's that's it right there so this is
this is I think the easiest way to
understand it you have an ideal so it's
a it's a subset of
no more facin endomorphisms our I saw
Chinese from a curve to itself okay so
there I saw Chinese they have kernels
okay so all of these endomorphs them
have kernels you have a set of
endomorphs it's an ideal so it's an
arithmetic it's like a sub rig right and
you're just gonna mod out by all of
those kernels right but but the
intersection of all the kernels not like
the Union right so you're gonna mount up
by the points the points that are
annihilated by everything in that idea
and so that's where you're I saw that's
you know you might look at the slide and
wonder where the isogen ease here yeah
this this the slash here that's the
assumption all right you're modding out
by a kernel right so that's the that's
what we call the complex multiplication
action and using this complex
multiplication action you can devise a
cryptosystem right and actually this
crypto system works for any group action
you don't need this particular you know
group action you could instantiate this
with any group action you want it just
so happens that of all the group actions
that we know this is the only one that
seems to be both secure and not just
like group multiplication or something
like that okay so it's it's very easy
conceptually right you have a group
action so you're just gonna act by a
secret a you're gonna act by a secret B
and then the shared secret will be
acting by both of them right here it's
very straightforward how to get from for
example be e to a be e you just multiply
by a it's a group action you can do that
okay so conceptually this is I think
quite simple there's there's a whole lot
of you know devil in the details stuff
about how to implement the group action
this is not straightforward how to
implement this perfection because the
this you know these isogen ease could
have large degree right and so you have
to worry about that a little bit but I'm
gonna let Chloe talk about that because
that's that's what she's talking about
all right so I'm just gonna treat this
action as a black box
alright and say that you know hey we
have a group action we can do a
cryptosystem let's understand its
security and so the viewpoint that I'm
going to take is sort of to frame this
as a hidden subgroup problem this this
this particular approach
was pioneered by Cooper Berg who is here
I hope I don't screw this up too bad
Greg so we're gonna talk about order
reframe this problem as a hidden
subgroup problem and there there are
there are sort of more recent papers
that that just sort of directly talk
about hidden shifts and and approach the
problem from that perspective but I'm
following sort of the older work I don't
want to step on the toes of like Chris
who's presenting this afternoon so I
decided safer to follow the older stuff
so in order to take this problem and
translate into translate it into a
hidden subgroup problem you're just
going to define a function on a suitable
group that sort of hides a subgroup
corresponding to the secret thing that
you're looking for and so this whole
slide is sort of starts from the same
premise as the previous slide except
that the notation differs so here my
notation is you know gothic letters for
ideals and group elements and things
like that here I've just got regular old
G for group element but it's that's the
same kind of setup so we have a group
action right here right and we have two
elements and we want to find sort of the
group element that translates one to the
other this is the this is the hard
problem that you need to solve in order
to break CRS or Seaside CRS and Seaside
both use the same the same setup at
least they're abstract terms okay so
here's how you do it you define a semi
direct product G with you know integers
mod to this particular semi direct
product then when you define a semi
direct product I guess you need you need
a sort of function I don't know what
this is called you need like a tying
function that ties the two you know
operands together and so your your
function here is boom that function okay
I say you tied them together with that
function and then you define a semi
direct product and then on the semi
direct product you'd if you could define
a hiding function it looks like this
okay and you can check that it is a
hiding function or in other words that
you know there's this promise that needs
to be satisfied that
of you know a group element equals F of
another group element if and only if
what if an if and only if like these two
group elements are like in the same
coset modulo a certain subgroup right
and that subgroup happens to be this
subgroup here and this subgroup has well
it's a subgroup of size two and one
element is the identity and the other
element is sort of the hidden element
that you're looking for like the secret
key in the proper in the in the crypto
system all right
gamma comma one ignore the one gamma is
your secret key right so you're looking
for this particular subgroup which is
hidden by this hiding function so that's
that's the perspective that we're gonna
take for the rest of our talk we want to
solve this hidden subgroup problem this
is on a dihedral group it's a it's a
semi direct product of an abelian group
by Zima two integers mod two and you
need that you need you need to do it
exactly this way in order to get a
hiding function with a group now this
group is not abelian right if it were
abelian we would know how to solve
hidden subgroup problems we abuse Shor's
algorithm on a quantum computer this
group is not abelian it's sort of as
close to abelian as you can get without
being abelian right as this large the
class group is abelian so G is abelian
but the semi direct product makes it not
appealing yeah so it's like sort of
almost but not quite a billion right
so all of this so this this sort of
approach is from Coover Berg's first
paper published in 2003 and it's it's an
algorithm for solving what we call the
dihedral hidden subgroup problem right
yes
that's fine we understand that you
understand that there's there's the
quantum part and actually so this this
talk is no there there are there are
certain things sort of in this if you go
ones speaking to this audience that are
a little bit awkward even for me as a
presenter right like you know maybe all
the quantum people who are here know
Cooper Berg's algorithm very well within
all the lattice people don't and so you
know I'm trying I'm trying sort of my
best to just you know the evil groups
aren't are solvable but they're not no
photos and I think the work on new
Pokemon community groups they're already
there had already been some and those
those really are closer to the billion
than this so so it's it's true that
they're close to the very closest it
just turned out just different from
expected but anyway all I was trying to
do was to say something new about any
case and I'm only learning photography
now all right thank thank you for that
clarification if I screw this up but
please please please do correctly
you pay here we get some credit we get
some credit thank you and if I mess
anything up please please do let me know
I'm very happy to receive Corrections
okay so to describe the algorithm for
the the half of the audience who who
isn't very familiar with quantum
algorithms I'm just gonna simplify some
more and assume that the abelian part
the G part is cyclic
all right so Z modulo n for some n right
so now we literally have a dihedral
group this is that I usually you know
from group theory it's a it's sort of
rotation groups with reflections all
right so that's the best thing about two
part is the reflections right now we're
gonna suppose how we have a hidden
subgroup which is one of these sort of
reflection groups right so when you
reflect its order to so it's one of
these reflection things and you're gonna
begin just like you do in Shor's
algorithm you make a superposition of
this hiding function over all you know
all the possible inputs right and so
well not all but you're gonna go over
all the dihedral but yeah yeah actually
all the passports so you're gonna make a
superposition over all the possible
inputs of you know D and F of D alright
and here you're gonna measure the second
register so this should be very familiar
if you know she'll gonna measure that
second register and then look at what
happens and to the first register after
you measure the second register right
actually you're going to throw away the
result of the measurement you don't care
about the second register anymore all
you care about is the first register
right so that first register once you
measure the second register the first
one instead of being a superposition
overall the group elements is gonna be a
superposition over like two of the group
elements it is this hiding function has
this guarantee sort of that it's this
two to one thing so now you have a
superposition over two things okay and
you can generate a lot of these you can
generate as many of these as you want
and you can't really control what you
get but you know the structure of what
you get is they're all gonna be things
that look like this so you have a whole
bunch of things that look like this and
then you apply your favorite tool from
quantum algorithm
the quantum Fourier transform and now
you get this object all right and so
that's what it looks like after you do
the quantum Fourier transform it's not a
it's not a sort of you know super easy
thing to work with but you can still you
there are things you can do with this
right and so what are you gonna do with
this is well let's see so it's some
summation over now now now the the you
know the these cyclic part right it's um
so nice the first qubit here the first
the first coordinate is some like you
know superposition over over the cyclic
part of the of the dihedral group okay
now you're gonna measure that and that
will give you an element of the cyclic
part that will give you some element of
the cyclic part and then now you're
gonna keep the second part over here so
so so we've gone here from you know
these two registers right the input and
the output we measured the output
discard it now we have the input but the
input itself is two coordinates right
that is the G Park and the zoom onto
part and so now given the quantum
Fourier transform this mess and then
you're going to measure the g part and
throw that a well not throw the like
measure the g part keep it keep it like
in the database so you know what it is
and then you have what's left is this
part in superposition right and this
part is sort of well it's 0 and 1 and
they're sort of offset by this this
phase right this this this this root of
unity right and what that root of unity
is depends on two things one is the
secret gamma that you're trying to find
the other is the k which is the k that
you measured in the first part and so
you're gonna keep that k and you're
going to keep this superposition and
we're going to call this I don't know
what what we're going to call this side
K all right there you go we're gonna
call it sigh okay and you could do this
many times all right so you do this many
many times many many times you get lots
and lots of sigh K's you can't control
you can't like pick and choose what K
you get but you know which one you got
because when you measure
the first register you know the K that
you measured so you get lots of the
essential you have a machine that
generates random side case and you know
what random outputs what random case you
got but you can't control what the
random case if you could control what
the random case were thing you would be
done right so here's a you know quick
sort of explanation of why that's the
case and you'll see that you know in
these in these kinds of algorithms it's
often very convenient to suppose that
your N is a power of two and so now I'm
gonna do that so we're simplifying even
more right and yet you can work around
all these problems you don't like this
is not the only case where the algorithm
works you don't have to simplify it this
way it just makes it easier to explain
right so suppose that N is a power of
two now right if you can construct psy K
and choose the K then you're done
because then you could construct you
could set K go to n over two basically
and then that would give you either 0
plus 1 or 0 minus 1 depending on whether
gamma is even or odd and something you
just measure with respect to this sort
of 45 degree basis and that will tell
you whether gamma is even or odd so that
gives you one bit of gamma one bit of
your secret right but then as as usual
with these kinds of things if you can
compute one [ __ ] thing you can like you
know engineer it so that you can then
successively determine more and more
bits right so you just need to you just
need to be able to compute like psy K
for some K of your choice and then
you're done okay so then the last part
to understand is that here you can sort
of control the K not really but you can
sort of control the K right and the way
that you do that is you can sort of even
you can you can even combine stasi like
inner product than work or ever you can
combine them tensor product you can
combine them in this way right so what
you do is you have two of these states
which I've called scipy inside q right
if you just combine them you know
multiply them directly you get this
which is not super useful but then you
can like control not what I have to sort
of figure out what this is you flip the
second bit
if and only if the first bit is one
right so your standard control not
operation here that turns this one into
zero this is their own two one and then
when you simplify this you get that mess
right here and then now you're gonna
measure the second register and that's
gonna be either zero or one if it was
zero then you got P plus Q here if it
was one then you got P minus 1 P minus Q
here okay so you can get either P plus Q
or P when you have scipy and sy q you
can't control the P you can't control
the Q but you know what the P is and you
know what the Q is so if you want it P
plus Q you could get that half the time
they'll have to happen you'll get P
minus Q okay so you have this sort of
you have this you have this hobbled you
know way of doing arithmetic where you
you can you can add things but you might
not add them half the time right so
you'll be successful half the time or if
you want to subtract subtract me you
could subtract them and you would be
successful half the time right your
saving grace is that you know whether or
not you got the plus or the minus right
because when you measure the second
register you'll know whether you got the
zero or the one okay you know which one
you got okay you know which one you got
and then now it's just a matter of
putting it all together right so imagine
that okay here's here's like the
formulation that lattice people might
understand better you have a lot of side
case for random K all right you want a
particular side K all right and you can
add and subtract the case that you have
which are random you can't control them
but you can add and subtract them all
right of course this has a cost you
can't just like add and subtract like
you know 10 to the 100 of these right so
what you need is you need like a short
linear combination a short integer
combination of the slidecage that you
have that lands in the K that you want
right and this is this is a lattice
problem this is exactly sort of a last
partly so this this sort of sieve that I
have on this slide is it's it's I think
in in cool roots papers you describe it
as reminiscent of either be kW or aks
one of those things right it's because
it's essentially one of these last beat
pkew is bloom coli Wasserman I don't
remember what a KS isn't the lattice
context yeah thank you
all right so it's one of it's one of
these things it's essentially a lattice
outgrowth right it's a little bit harder
than the lattice case because you can't
control the what what operation you get
right you can't you can't just always
get a plus or always get them eyes you
you get one or the other half times so
it's just a little harder but not too
much harder you could work around that
you can work around that just by
essentially doubling at each stage the
number of sort of inputs that you
combine right so that when you're
successful half the time you still get
the number of successes that you need
right so there's what you you start with
a whole bunch of quantum states for
random case right forward to the square
root of login of them right and you
group them into buckets according to
their last order log n bits right and
you're gonna zero out these bits right
starting from the least significant
bucket I guess and then working your way
up right so to zero all these bits what
you're gonna need is well you're gonna
need to subtract right if they have the
same lower sort of log n bits you have
to subtract them to zero out those bits
that only works half the time right so
there you go
it works half the time if it works you
have you you destroyed two states right
you don't get to keep the states after
you combine them they that are gone
right but then I have a new state right
so if it works you destroyed the inputs
and you have an output if it doesn't
work you destroyed the inputs and you
got nothing out of it right so on
average you destroy four inputs to
create one right that's where that four
comes from in the base right and you
have to do this whole thing squared of
login times because there are a square
root of log in a sort of buckets of
square root of log in bits each right so
you do this whole thing square root of
log in times and then you can control
the state to be whatever you want at the
end right not just zeros but you can get
any binary sequence that you want in
there and so that's that's how you do
and this this gets you sort of one bit
okay that's my last slide I think I'm
done I'll happily take any questions and
you know for all the rest I defer to
Chloe and Chris who will talk much more
about this stuff
[Applause]
it's probably a dumb question but your
shared secret at the end of the protocol
is some elliptic curve is there a
concern that like needs some canonical
representation of these that's a good
that's a good question
look the question is I don't know if I
need to repeat it you your shared C
chord is an elliptic curve do you need
some canonical representation of the
curve in case two people like come up
with the same curve but represent it
differently or something like that the
answer is in practice yes we use a
canonical representation
it's called Wow
the what we described in our original
paper for si th is to use the J
invariant the J invariant is an
isomorphism invariant of the elliptic
curve any two isomer if it curves have
the same J invariant and so no matter
how you do this you're gonna get at the
very very least you're gonna get
isomorphic shared secrets at the end and
so Jay invariant does the job for you
in practice nowadays what we do is we
use curves in Montgomery forum and for a
Montgomery forum it's not convenient to
use the jamierand does more community to
use the a invariant but the same
principle applies that you know you can
you can guarantee that they invariance
will be the same so your chefs secret
ends up being just some number that you
compute over the curve yes your shared
secret ends up being an element over the
field FP or for s ith to the field is
actually F P squared
[Applause]